the next speaker is jose ovel from tel
aviv university
so he's an expert in in bats
and uh
sorry uh so he did his uh uh
he did his um bachelor and master's
degree at tel aviv university
and um uh his phd uh
to binge mpi and then uh joined as a
professor
university so i should say that that uh
well uh once working in the ben gurion
airport in israel
i i've seen his face appearing on on the
wall uh
basically there was an exposition that
showcases some
uh research and science down in israel
and he was one of the
the people featured there so i guess uh
in the um
in the interest of time uh the floor is
yours
thanks uh michael thanks for inviting me
uh okay you can see it now in uh
presentation mode right you can see my
uh
my presentation yep okay great
so uh so hi everybody i'm going to talk
a lot about bad communication but before
that i should say not bad in germany
sometimes they
misspell mispronounced tsd and i was
once
presented as a very as the student of a
very famous bad researcher but
the word is bat and before i talk about
communication i want to
tell you a few words about about
sociality really just one slide
so what are bats actually talking about
so here's one example hopefully the the
movies will play
and so apparently there are different
types of bats in a fruit bath colony
for instance if you place a bowl of
fruit in the center of the colony so now
on the left hopefully the movie
can hopefully you can see it the bat
lands on the bowl of fruit and takes
some food and
flies with it to the ceiling we call
this a producer the term was invented
mostly by bird researchers we
did not invent these terms
but something like 30 percent of the
individuals in the colony will never go
down to the bold food they would prefer
to go
to some other specific individual and
scrounge food directly from
its mouth and i already gave you the the
answer when we looked at these
preferences and this is the network down
here this is what it represents
we found that these are specific
preferences so this is a producing
scrounging network
where for example this arrow means that
this individual prefers
significantly to scrounge food over a
month from this individual
we later on analyzed so you can see
there are two colors here and i can tell
you that the colors are females and
males
and we later on also found that many of
these ties not all of them are related
to mating so the females seem to be
testing
the males by scrounging food from them
this is of course an interpretation
and at the end they at the end of the
season of the mating season they
they mate with one of these males
probably the one with which they created
the strongest bond although of course
this is my
human interpretation now many of these
interactions we're still talking about
fruit bats you'll see several types of
species of fats in this talk and many of
these interactions are
accompanied by sound so here's an
example
i don't know if you can hear me can you
hear me
six
okay so i think you could not hear me
while the movie was playing
but what you saw okay thanks right um
were interactions between bats in our
colony
after foraging and before falling asleep
at the end you could see them clustered
uh sleeping this is their nightly
cluster or their daily cluster i should
say
and they can spend hours in these
arrangement fights or whatever and you
could hear that there's a lot of
communication going on
and now i want to take you into a bad
colony i'll say this before you see the
movie
a bad colony with thousands of
individuals still footbats and see what
it
or hear or listen to what it sounds like
okay so here it is okay so the the
question the first question that i want
to present the first question that we
studied
is what kind of information is embedded
in these uh agonistic aggressive calls
okay
if you enter a food bath colony it
sounds like they're constantly
fighting with each other it seems
meaningless you know to invest so much
energy in vocalization without
it conveying some information by the way
you can see the students
for each of the studies you can see the
students who are
uh who carried out all of the research i
can tell you by the way that i
and and you know if i train you quite
quickly you will also be able to
uh to distinguish some of the holidays
in this cacophony so i can hear the
the pups for example but we will come
back to this later on
so of course uh recording bats in this
environment would be
it would be possible but the data would
be impossible for us so we had to go
into a more
controlled setup and before i show you
the setup i just want to
um show you what the calls look like so
these are stack to grounds okay we saw
spectrograms yesterday
but just in case it's a it's a
representation of sound we have time on
the x-axis and
and frequency on the on the y-axis and
energy
is depicted by by color and you can see
here the repertoire of part of the
repertoire of
fruit bats so these are mating
vocalizations emitted by a male
while mating these are isolation calls
emitted by or distress calls emitted by
a pop we will come back to them later
and this is very typical to a very angry
individual these are echolocation calls
we'll come back to them later
too but the big majority of
organizations at least
in the colony look like this okay so
there are aggressive calls
and this is the the the corpus of uh of
recordings that we are focusing on on
this study
we were wondering whether we can extract
more information than just saying
these are aggressive localization okay
so this is what the setup looks like
we actually created many small bat
colonies and we divided the colony into
two parts you know it's very small but
still we divide it into
where they sleep and where they feed and
the idea is basically to get
very high quality a lot of data you'll
see in a second how much in
very high quality everything is covered
with foam so we you know the
recordings have very few echoes we're
recording around the clock
we're recording everything basically for
several months and this gives us a
database
originally with millions of
organizations but after we
filter them to good vocalizations we go
down to hundreds of thousands
and after we annotate them okay so for
each
interaction we we detect who is the
emitter who is the addressee
what was the context in a second i'll
come back to what does this mean what
does
this context mean and only for these
twenty thousand organizations we then
run our study it's still a big database
but but much smaller you know than the
one we started with
but it's annotated and and of course you
can see this huge reduction
maybe you're wondering why is it such a
such a huge reduction the reason is
that if just if we're sure about this
information
do we count this as an annotated
vocalization so we just throw out
everything we're not
sure about we can still use this right
for unsupervised um
algorithm for example like mikhail just
discussed
so i want to show you what an
interaction looks like in one of these
small colonies it's all with the
security cameras because you know we
can't create
anyway we're creating tons of data so
we're trying to limit this
so this is what the interaction looks
like hopefully the movie will play
okay this movie is always a bit
problematic but
what i want to remind you is the that
the bats
actually experience experience the same
interaction like this right because
they're perching in the dark
it's mostly dark and they see this or
feel this or perceive this as something
like this
okay so what we're actually asking in
this study is whether
when sorry my presentation is stuck
okay whether when hearing such an
interaction
a third bat that is listening whether it
can say something
about who is the emitter and
who is the addressee what is the context
i'll come back to this in a second
and also maybe something about the
outcome what is going to be the outcome
of the interaction
okay so what do i mean by context i
mentioned this several times obviously
and this is a huge limitation something
i'm willing to discuss later on we can
only uh define context that we can see
with our eyes okay so that's our human
at least with this type of supervised
approach this is our human
bias and we detected four types of
interactions so they are they're all
aggressive i remind you or we at least
see them as aggressive
so you have interactions over food okay
they look
like this
okay so one individual had a piece of
fruit another one was trying to scrounge
and these are mating aggressive
interactions but this is not what you've
seen before in this case the female is
kind of
aggressive towards the male that he's
trying to mate
okay we have fighting with no clear
reason that we can detect
and probably the favorite of my my
favorite at least is the sleeping
interactions because it's to me so human
they're sleeping in a cluster one
individual wakes up it's moving the
other one and the other one is
shouting at it or something like that
okay so now you understand the data in
terms of the analysis we're using a
supervised algorithm
and we're not using a neural network
although we tried neural networks as
well
and the data is presented there's a as a
male
as male capsule coefficient and we can
discuss this later we tested many
different organizations it didn't really
change the results much
and our classifier is a gaussian mixture
model
or a type of gaussian mixture model
which is known as a gmm uvm it has some
kind of a background model
which is very common in speech
processing
and as i said we tried other approaches
the results were quite similar
okay what i want to to emphasize here is
that
for those of you who don't know this the
fact that we're using capsule
coefficient means that we're just
looking at the frequency we're not
looking at temporal information at all
although i think it is very important so
this is probably an underestimate
to what bats can do and here are the
results okay so graphically they're
quite boring and we're looking at the
confusion matrices so basically what
does this what this means is that
we have seven individuals here so this
is for uh taking a vocalization and
predicting
the emitter so we're looking at seven
backs for which we had most data
and this is our prediction and this is
the true class and if the diagonal okay
so this means that we're right 80
for example for bat number three more or
less okay it's the balance accuracy for
those of you know that
what that means and but basically if the
diagonal is
yellow it means that we are doing well
so we can take one of these aggressive
organizations and say quite accurately
accurately who is the emitter okay based
the frequently
i can ask a quick question uh where do
you have the ground truth about the
emitter how to uh find yeah so
so this if you remember that huge
reduction from
a hundred sixty thousand to twenty
thousand that is because
we manually observed the field the
videos we now have an automatic method
to do this
but we manually observe the films we
have the videos we have
multiple students doing this we do
cross-validation and we throw out
everything that we're not sure about
okay so it took a huge amount of time
just to annotate
this data set very hard to do
automatically so
you know if i could for example maybe
detect the emitter automatically but
detecting the
context would be probably impossible um
and this is another explanation maybe i
didn't say this
why we had to reduce the size of our
colony to small colonies okay if i had
20 bats there
i would not be able to to say who is the
emitter okay
today we do have a method to do this but
still i would lose a lot of information
before they know from one day to the
next that this is the same bat or is it
all within the same day
no no they're all marked of course
they're all marked we know over three
months that these are the same
of course yeah as you can see i can also
do well above chance
in in predicting uh
what is the context so out of these four
contexts that i've
described earlier on so i can take a
vocalization and say whether the bats
were fighting
over sex over food
over sleep or without the reason that i
can see
and interestingly we also can say
something again everything is compared
to chance
so there is some information even if
it's far from perfect about the address
c
okay this is the one something that
surprised us but i can say
whether a female or a male is being
approached and to some extent i can also
take
all of the females for example that have
been approached and say above chance
level significantly which
female is being addressed uh you know if
we think of humans and we
uh androphomophiles this is a problem
then this makes some sense right when i
approach one individual
using the same organization it might
sound differently
than when i approach you know my boss
versus a friend for example
and also to some extent we could say
something about the outcome
of the popularization so we define two
outcomes whether the bats stay together
or whether they separate
after this aggressive interaction so
this is actually the
these are the conclusions of the first
project that i wanted to present that
has to do with the
information and conveyed by this
aggressive localization
all of this i've already said it's a
single vocalization that we use and
we're using spectrum
or or spectral features only
the next story that i want to tell you
has to do with the ontogeny
of a of vocal communication so this was
mentioned yesterday
already regarding the elephants there's
a big question about whether animals and
mammals specifically
learn their vocalization their vocal
repertoire or whether it is innate
and basically the very few
mammalian models of course songbirds are
very known
for their ability to learn vocalizations
but they're very few
and mammalian models and for which it is
it has been robustly shown that they
learn the vocalizations
now and we wanted to test this with bats
there were a few previous publications
with other species of bats
suggesting that they might be learning
um
and what i'm showing you here is just a
an image
representation of the ontogeny so
all vocalizations uh start with this
what i call
an isolation or a distress call that
pops you could think of this as crying
basically so
from day zero when you take a pop you
move it you put it alone
this is the vocalization that it will
emit it's a rather high in pitch i will
play it back to you now but
it's high in pitch and not very loud so
i'm not sure you will hear it i'll try
okay i don't know if you if you heard
this but when i said it in the cacophony
i can hear the pops crying this
i can i can hear my ears still allow me
and and you can see
how over a period of uh uh almost a year
okay so this is day 150
these vocalizations uh turn into
this adult like sequence that we've seen
before okay and the question is whether
perhaps need to hear adults
in order to evolve this uh this
okay and in order to do this you know to
study this there are several classical
ways in the
literature one is uh to perform an
isolation
experiment in which you deprive the pups
on the ability to hear
a dots and that's a exactly what we did
so we had perhaps isolated with their
mothers okay so the power
was with its mother which is important
for the development of the power
but luckily the pup and the mother
hardly
communicate hardly communicate and uh we
of course we control it for this we
check this
and the reason is that the pup is under
the mother's wing
okay and it's uh it's connected to the
to the nipple
and therefore there's hardly any
interaction so the pup actually
mostly listens to the adult interactions
this is something i'll come back to
in the next story and you see what you
can see here is over time okay so this
is day 210
i'm comparing and this is for all so we
extracted different acoustic features
and if i look at all acoustic features
this is some kind of an
average and i compare them to the adults
so you can see that the control pops the
ones that
the ones that they that were exposed to
adults
okay to adult communication uh converge
quickly or
within a hundred days to the adult while
the
isolated pups stay or lag far behind
okay it seems that in the end
they might be converging we're not
exactly sure what's going on here
but definitely you can say that there is
a very substantial delay
in their vocal ontogeny which suggests
that there is some
role of learning you can see this here
for this for the for the pitch or the
fundamental frequency actually only okay
so for a specific
vocal feature you can see the same
pattern now we were you know okay so
there is some kind of lag but what's
going on here we're trying to say
something more
conclusive about what's going on here so
hopefully this side says a little bit
more about
where is this delay coming from what i'm
showing you here over time okay you can
see day
0 to 70 70 to 140 140 to 240 and
we are now looking at a um a two
feature space okay so we're two we're
looking at two acoustic features the
fundamental frequency and winner of the
entropy
you can plot others of course and the
black area
is the adult region so adult
vocalizations will be within this region
and you can see how the control parts
they start all over the place
but somehow as if they are guided they
converge quite quickly onto the adult
range but if you look at the pop
vocalizations you can see that the
majority of organizations
uh converge to the right area but you
still have a lot of this
it's really dispersed still so you still
have a lot of organizations
that are outside the adult range so it
is if
they are lacking this guidance it's as
if hearing adults
guides you which vocalizations to use
it's not that they cannot emit
that like vocalizations but more that
they need this guidance in order to
converge onto the right
regime okay so it seems to be a mixture
of of
innate some conseminator components but
also there is some kind of learning
now of course when you isolate the pops
already hinted on this some some people
could say um
okay these pups have no mothers and this
affects me oh sorry they have their
mother but they don't have
any they they're not they don't observe
any social interactions
so maybe it's not vocal learning but
something is wrong with their sociality
so this is why we came up with the
following uh
experiment so it's a different study and
what we did here is to
have both so we have three groups of
pubs control and two manipulations
and all groups of pubs are with their
mothers in a group so we have
six pops and mothers normal colonies
small colony but normal colony they can
they're exposed to adult interactions
so they hear their parents or or mostly
their mothers
but in addition to hearing their mothers
and we also manipulate them by placing
speakers in the colony
and playing back a if you wish a dialect
and
it's hard to say whether it's an accent
or a dialect right because we don't know
if these are words or what exactly these
vocalizations will represent but we uh
play back
a subsample of the vocal repertoire so
you can see this here
along the the fundamental frequency you
can see the control so this is the
normal distribution of fundamental
frequencies
green is the control group this is what
they hear a blue
is the low pitch group and red is the
high pitch group this is what they
heard so i always say you know i always
when i when i give a public
talk i say it's like taking a family
and moving from one city to another from
london to glasgow for example so the
children
are exposed to both the dialect of their
parents
at home but also to the new dialect
where they moved
into and the you know there are many
analysis to show i just want to
um i just want to to show one um
slide that summarizes this and what you
see here
are a linear discriminants or you could
think of this as the principal
components basically
and we're plotting and this is time okay
so again you have the day
so this is one year okay and you can see
the three groups you can see that to
begin with the three groups
are all together more or less red green
and blue
and you can see how over time they split
into three
groups and importantly it's not as if we
are running
a discriminant analysis on the data of
the pups right because then we would
find some separation
what we've done here is to run the
discriminant analysis
on the adults okay on on the playback
sorry not only adults but on the
playback of the adults
that they were exposed to so these axes
represent
the playback the manipulation and you
can see that on this
in this space uh we the pops so we
didn't don't do anything the pubs
separate
into these three groups suggesting once
again that there is
a a role of learning in addition to some
innate role
and to someone simulate component in
their
acquisition of their vocal repertoire we
call this
a crowd vocal learning okay because you
know most
studies on vocal learning mostly in
birds but not only they talk about the
tutor so one-to-one interaction and how
important this is even with humans okay
this is
apparently very important but in this
case we're talking about learning from
the group basically
uh right because we have this playback
so the pups actually are
even though they hear their mothers the
group or the cacophony that they hear in
the background
influences their their vocal autogeny
and if you think of this movie that i
showed you earlier this is probably not
surprising so
imagine a perhaps under its mother's
wing
in one of in one of these and this is
what is it exposed to so
it's hard to to imagine how it can
really learn from its mother at least in
this
[Music]
colony
[Music]
okay um if you have any questions this
is a good time
maybe if there's any question from the q
a well
it's long so maybe we'll postpone it um
one second i'm looking oh no this is
from bihar
i will not answer my house questions um
[Music]
you have one question in the bottom yeah
yeah i'm reading it
i'm stopping now to answer because the
next two studies that i will show you
are completely different and i'll kind
of finish talking about the
vocal learning and communication in the
lab and now i'm going to take you out to
the field
so sorry i just read the question um
[Music]
yeah yeah okay good so the question is
whether
um we looked at the it's a very it's a
question
that is often asked it's regarding the
first study where i showed you that
there is some kind of information a
classifier was able
to say something about what is
the context for example but we're using
these mfcc's it's not very intuitive
and the question is which features allow
distinguishing and the different
contacts and maybe i know how does the
distribution look like that's my
interpretation of the question
so the answer is yes uh
we also looked did run the same study by
doing the feature analysis the one that
i presented in the
in the second and third study but if you
look at the
the distributions they don't cluster
very nicely and sometimes you see with
songbirds for example
maybe this is an important point an
important point to
to talk about once again for some reason
my presentation is not going backwards
okay so uh if you look at these
vocalizations
they're very noisy actually they're
they're reminiscent of vocal of
human speech they're higher in pitch but
they're similar in their noisiness okay
these are not easy
um tonal vocalizations that you can very
easily classify
and that's a big problem that we have
and so they don't cluster very nicely
into into any group
any clear group and when you do run some
kind of you know
disney analysis or something like that
and you look at context
i have this slide later very very late
on and i don't want to break the
presentation
and you do see some kind of separation
in space
okay but it doesn't cluster very nicely
it looks like a big continuum
which is something that we've been
thinking about a lot for example if you
want to talk about
syntax for example you need some kind of
clustering okay and that's something
that
which i think is very general for many
animal organizations you lack this
ability
to cluster them nicely
okay so since i still have some time
i'm going to move a little bit from from
communication
and show you how we studies these
animals in the field and how we plan to
connect this to communication so
everything i showed you so far was in
the lab
okay even though i'm i always advocate
for studying
animals in the field and that was due to
their to our inability to record them
nicely in the field i
explained i think i explained why but in
the past
several years we've been developing the
ability to record animals
in the field including their
vocalizations okay so what you can see
here
is a miniature device that we yourself
um develop it
includes a gps you can see here the
movement of bats i will not be talking
about these bats today these are nectar
feeding bats
that fly hundreds of kilometers every
night okay you can see gps data over
here
and we have a microphone on this setup
this is the microphone actually
and in a second i'll show you what kind
of data we get from the microphone
obviously we get
a vocal communication but we also can do
more
and we have an accelerometer you can see
here the wing beat of the animal
in red we have a physiology sensor so
you can see here for example
a ecg data recorded on board the animals
so you can basically record
many types of you can also connect the
camera but it makes everything much more
difficult but we can record many many
types of information
now i said that the microphone gives us
a lot of information
here it is what i mean and you have to
remember that most bats equal okay
which means that they use sound in order
to sense the world
okay and i'll show you later on soon how
this sensory how these sensory
vocalizations can also be used
for communication by the bats okay this
is why i'm talking about this in this
in this meeting uh so what do we see
here so we see spectrograms once again
and these are echolocation calls
okay you can see they're multiharmonic
in this case in this bad you can see
that they're
ultrasonic so this is 25 kilohertz more
or less
and note that i can study interactions
between bats because when i have a
microphone on the back i can also record
it it's called sphinx these are nearby
bats okay so i can study interactions
for example
instead of sensor interference for
example i know
based on sound only when a bat is
attacking prey okay so what you see here
is a feeding buzz it's very important
and i'll come back to this later on
and you see that the the calls there are
many things here the change you see the
intervals are becoming shorter the cores
are becoming weaker
and shorter themselves this means that
the bat is attacking food and i can
see this even when the bat is flying you
know a thousand meters above ground or
somewhere
wherever it is right above the desert in
the border of mexico and
between mexico and the u.s eh sometimes
i know what is being attacked
so for example this is the frog eating
bat in panama
the frog is also emitting sound
vocalizations okay i can see i can
record them
and i know that the tundra frog has been
attacked and which is one of the
favorite
uh prey types of this bat and so
the bat itself by the way is also using
these vocalizations in order to find the
prey
and in this case i even know that this
was the last call
emitted by the frog and this is based on
the chewing sounds
right after the attack so i even know to
some extent
whether the attack was successful or not
so i can do all of this using sound this
is actually one of the reasons why i
claim that studying bats in the wild has
huge advantages try to extract this
information for an animal
without observing it and um
one of the questions that we studied
using this system
is a is indeed sociality and forging
socially i will describe the movie
before
you see it because again i'm not sure
you'll hear me so in a second i'll play
this movie and you will see thousands of
uh they're called greater mousetail bats
you can see them already here
aggregating at the
exit of the cave and you'll see them
flying out you will hear them what you
will hear
is social vocalization there are there's
a lot of social
communication going on before they
emerge so you can't hear the echo
location
and then the the camera will turn and
you can see
for a second you'll see the lake of
galilee so these bats are flying towards
the lake of galilee
so
okay i hope you could see the i was
pointing towards the lake of galilee
so and i forgot to say this is just
before sunset oh sorry
just after sunset okay so it's still
still it's there's still
light but it's just after sunset you
could see a kestrel a predator trying to
get one of the birds say
i couldn't speak during the movie and i
like to think
that 2000 years ago jesus was walking on
the lake of galilee and he looked up and
saw this swarm of bats
flying above him and then he probably
asked himself two questions
okay so the first one is how do they
avoid sensor interference
and i'm not going to talk about this
today it's a huge problem
they're all emitting calls at the same
frequencies we have several studies
published
about this one very very recent
and the second problem that i want to
talk about the second question
is are they operating together these
bats are they doing something together
and i'll give you the answer already the
answer is we believe they are and here
is why
so this is the bat by the way greater in
mouse about 35 grams one of the smallest
animals ever tracked using gps um
and you can see that this animal so
during summer this animal
searches for queen ants that are flying
so performing a nuptial flight
so it's a very difficult search and you
can see it here okay so this is the
movement looking green and blue look at
the scale
it moves dozens of kilometers every
night it moves so blue is one night the
green is another night
so it's a very exhaustive search so we
call this a
search for ephemeral food okay you have
to move very very far there's no way to
predict
where food is going to be and you have
to search
a lot and without going into the details
what we show is that the bats are
constantly moving in a group okay
so it's not only that they emerge as a
group they are constantly moving in a
group okay this is something about the
density of the bats but really instead
of going to detail i'll just show you an
example so this is one individual
okay it's the same blue trajectory over
here and i overlaid
in a red in a red flag you can see
wherever the bat is attacking food
and in green you can see wherever the
bat is flying near other bats okay so
it's constantly flying near other bats
i should say our microphone is much less
sensitive than the bat
so if i don't see a bad nearby it
doesn't mean that there is no back
so this is estimate and you can still
see that the bats are constantly moving
together
we see this for several bats okay this
is one of the
one of the most fascinating budget i
know it's called the mexican fish eating
that it
roosts on these islands in the sea of
quarters between baja california and
mexico
and it has this very difficult task very
similar to the other bat i showed you it
has to fly off the island these are our
gps tracks for the first time we
reveal what these bats do and it has to
fly
dozens of kilometers in search of once
again ephemeral prey prey that is hard
to predict
it it fishes it eats fish orchestrations
on the island on the ocean sorry and
um it doesn't dive in by the way okay it
collects them
with a with its uh claws
and i'll show you now a movie and i
don't know if you'll hear me so i'll say
uh already now what you're going to see
and you'll see bats flying off the
island
it's going to be several hours per back
but shortened compressed in time they
fly back
and you will see two type two circles
white circles whenever there's a nearby
bat and red circles whenever they're
feeding
and note that how they are constantly
moving with other bats
in nearby now can you hear me now
yes okay so this movie is silent so in
this case you can hear me
so you could see for example here the
bat found a patch
or a school of fish or something like
this and it's foraging but more
important for this stock
is are these red white circles okay
suggesting that also when they move
between
foraging patches they are always moving
in a group
okay so the interpretation the
conclusion is
you know let's say the hypothesis is
positive
oops the hypothesis is
okay that they're searching that somehow
moving in a group helps them
and we actually prove this uh
by using a simulation of course hard to
prove analytically but
the idea is basically that if the food
is
patchily distributed so this is a
schematic suggesting what's going on
if there's a lot of food and you move in
a group this is beneficial
why because um each individual bat
can search a very very small range okay
using echo location you can only see a
few meters ahead so i would say it's
like driving on the highway using a
small flashlight it's very difficult
but you can eavesdrop on other
individuals okay this is this huge range
and you can hear other individuals
from more than 100 meters more than 100
meters sorry
and you know when others find food how i
showed you this
um this feeding bus earlier on right a
few slides ago
so when somebody else finds food you
know this if you can eavesdrop on it
this is why
this bag of chips appears here because
we always said it's like a bag of chips
if somebody opens a bag of chips in a
in a dark theater everybody knows their
food there is food
over there so um i want to
in addition you know to explaining this
and we actually simulate it too
here's a simulation of this using a very
uh
i hope you can hear me but it's a very
typical a
simple it's what's known as a three
brady collective movement
model and you can see that using this
same schematic
the same idea that i showed you earlier
on the bats form a
group and there's some food over here
and indeed we showed that
using this approach they will find food
faster than when they're moving
alone and but in addition to showing
why collective movement assists them i
want to point out again to this message
that there is no vocal real vocal
communication communication going on
even though these bats have vocal uh
communication
they communicate a lot as we heard in
the cave for example
and while flying they don't need this
they know what the others are doing
just by eavesdropping on their
echolocation
signals okay hopefully you could hear me
during the movie if not somebody say
something
the last thing i want to show you i'm
going to take you completely out of the
communication world and talk about the
different types of cognition and how we
can use this
technology in order to study cognition
and i'm going to talk about cognitive
maps will take me a few minutes only
hopefully
and just in case you don't know what the
cognitive map is
and the idea is that you have and it's
highly debated which animals including
humans have cognitive maps so the idea
that you
that if you have a cognitive map you
contain or there's not the wrong world
but
words but you have some kind of a mental
map of the environment in your brain you
hold it in your brain okay maybe that's
a better word
and and how do i know if somebody has a
cognitive map so the hallmark or
one way to test this is to show that you
can create shortcuts okay so if you look
at this bat we tracked this bat in the
wild for for almost 100 nights
and look how far it moves so it flies 25
kilometers to point a
for many nights and then it flies to
point b and then it flies
on c for many nights and then it
performs something that looks like a
shortcut
okay but the idea why i like this
example is that this still doesn't prove
or even doesn't hint towards the
cognitive map and that is because
in order to prove a map or to suggest
the map
and you need to show that this is a
novel shortcut right it could be that
this bad performance maybe it was flying
with a map
right maybe it was flying with gps a few
years earlier maybe just flying behind
its mother
okay so we can't say that this is novel
novel because we don't know the history
of the animal
okay by the way these animals can live
up to 40 years so the history
is a long history so in order to
overcome this challenge
we invented the following idea we
created our own
um colony so our bats roost in tel aviv
university
but they are free they can do whatever
they want they fly out and come back
not all come back by the way and this
allows us now to
to monitor the same animal from the day
it is born okay so i can show you now
i'm showing you now sorry three nights
of an adult not a newborn
in our pub and you can see nicely how
this individual for example
uh go so each color is a different night
and you can
see our individual like this individual
flies over it finds another colony also
very interesting for me
and sleeps over at friends then comes
back and then
and sleeps in our colony and similarly
we will have bats from this colony
coming and sleeping over
in our equality so our colony is really
part of the network of colonies in the
environment and now i'll show you
an individual i think it's something
like 69 one individual
you'll see all of its movements again
i'm describing the movie in case you
can't hear me
and you will see every color is a
different night you will see how it
increases it's a foraging and
exploration range
from blue to red so it's the same bat
over something like 60 nights from day
zero from the first night
outside
okay so the knights are moving from a
blue to red see how there are a lot of
nights where it goes back to familiar
locations but there are also
lights where it explores right and
i should say day zero is the first night
of this vet outside but it's not its
first night in life
okay so this is something around a 40 or
40 to 60 for this back but now when i
see the bat flying over here
and coming back so i look at the yellow
the yellow that this is the red
i know it is never ever been in this
area and still it is able to come back
in a rather direct headline okay so i
can now
look at your journey of navigation you
can see how the bats increase
their exploration i already showed you
already showed you this the good thing
about these bags is that they are fruit
bar
that's that unlike the the fishing thing
but i showed you earlier on
they go back to the same trees again and
again so when i see a bed so we
mapped more than one thousand trees used
by our birds and when i see a bat
arriving at the tree from a family tree
i can guess imagine i prophesied
that that's where it was aiming for
unlike with fish eating bats where you
never know what the bat is
aiming to do and now i'm going to give
you a very very brief overview of the
results
and basically we showed that the bats um
have the ability to perform shortcuts
and indeed novel shortcuts so you can
see
an example of a shortcut in blue pink is
what the bat perform
before the during the same night before
the shortcut this is some kind of
forging tree
and then you can see the shortcut we
have shortcuts up to 20 kilometers this
is 500 meters but
it can be much longer and i know this is
novel because in white
you can see everything the bat did
before this okay so i have the full
history of the bat
we detect hundreds of shortcuts or or
actually
more slightly more than a 200 shortcuts
and
and here are just a few examples yeah
we're not going to it but we also show
that these are
based probably based on vision so
although these bats use the collocation
the collocation is a short-range
and sensory system and when navigating
like this
they are probably using vision
and um a fundamental a big question was
for what age can they perform shortly
because
and if a day outside and we find that it
it doesn't change over time so you can
see this here the number
the rate of shortcutting over time and
it seems to be completely
a uniform maybe except for the first few
days
so the pads have the ability to perform
shortcuts from day
zero outside again not day zero in life
but if you look at the
overall distance of the shortcuts and
you can see that this is increasing okay
so obviously
the more they map the environment
over here for example the longer the the
shortcuts can be
right but they can perform shortcuts
they can this is for example a very
early day
they can perform these shortcuts from
day zero
and the last thing i want to say is okay
so how do they
learn the environment and this is a
whole new study unpublished yet
but recently submitted in which we look
at the interaction between mothers and
pups during this
ontogeny of navigation and the
the thing is i'm not sure how many of
you know this that uh
in this week which is on home species
and mothers fly
with their bats attached to them at
least for
a long period and we actually know that
the bat is attached
attached to the mother because we have
an accelerometer on the mother and on
the back
we have gps but also an accelerometer
and you can see here the acceleration
of the mother and the pup and you can
see how they are perfectly
you know synchronized with the phase
shift right because the the mother is
flapping is going up and down the
accelerometer on the pump is reversed
and therefore you see this
this antiphase but they're perfectly
synchronized so we know exactly when the
pup is
on the mother like over here and when it
is not on the mother so here the mother
is flying
but the pup is stationary and what we
find
is that the mothers place the bats from
a certain age they fly out with them
but they then place them on certain
trees within a
radius of up to seven kilometers from
the roost and then later on in life
after a few weeks and the pups will
start flying independently to these
trees specifically
so they seem to be learning from the
mothers even though they never flew
independently they're always carried
uh carried their own by the mothers so
they are learning passively
while they are being carried on by the
models
and so i finished this is uh finished a
little bit early i think so
that's good you have you have your break
you can all go out and drink our
coffee together in the corridor and i
just have to thank a lot of students who
collected
this data some of which i mentioned
already and a lot of collaborators and
funding agencies
and that's it thank you very much i'll
be glad to answer the questions
thank you very much really wonderful
talk very uh
very exciting and uh well uh it seems
that that
we have a lot a lot to learn from from
the bats
um so i think there are several
questions in the q a
and uh also in the main uh in the main
chart
i think that in the chat yeah in the q a
i don't see anything new let me know if
something appears
and in the in the chat no this is the q
a how to open the chat
i started a second ago okay hey
let's see where are my questions
i think starting with have you been able
to track the path of individual learning
that's me or that's
earlier on the time two day
two down yeah ah okay great
luigi okay um
for food
[Music]
yeah if i understand the question how do
they count the women to follow
okay great uh so if i understood the
question this
is relating to the collective movement
the the where i showed you the fish
eating bags
basically and i was quick there i didn't
know i will have so much time
left over the idea at least how we
imagine it and how we modeled it and it
works uh
is that there is no communication so
nobody shouts i found food
okay and i don't have time to go back to
the movie i will not do it but i'll be
happy to supply it to anyone
and so nobody's shouting there is food
and the only
the only guys who know that food was
found are the ones that are
eavesdropping on the ones that already
found the food
okay so basically only know what the
bats within iron meters for you
are doing but still information
propagates through this
group uh i call it i like to think of it
as some kind of an avalanche of
information
so the first individual finds food and
then
the ones around it find the food and the
ones next
come closer because they're moving in
this direction
and they fight the food too obviously
not everybody finds the food so
if you pay attention to the example that
i showed uh you could see that some
uh the part of the group actually
diverged
away from the food okay so it's
definitely not an optimal solution
but the nice thing is that it's very
very cheap on communication so there's
no leadership there's no direct
communication
you just eavesdrop and you still perform
much better than
a as an individual
yeah so i think the next question is
related do they have a collective memory
and not to throw for food in the same
location yeah it's a
it's a fantastic question i haven't
tested it
and i imagine that you could look at the
movement of the individual
of an individual you have to remember
one of our
one of our caveats is always we track a
few individuals within the
group within the swarm and we have to uh
from this to deduce what's the
collective doing
yeah i i i'm thinking now out loud
and myself can help me whether you could
use the movement
of the group of the individual story and
say something about whether the memory
is not
individual but collective but definitely
you can see the
movement that suggests that they're not
going back to places where they
they've been before but i have to think
about it a little bit more uh
assuming they can map sorry oops no jump
down sorry so they came up in
environment
and learn from others they had to expect
symbolic learning yeah i would love to
show that
of course our our dream is to find the
you know the the be
dance for bats um we have no evidence
for this so far
okay so we don't have any evidence that
they really provide information
and you know unlike social insects you
have to remember that these are
basically selfish it's a collective of
selfish individuals
so we don't have any uh any evidence for
this but
obviously this is something we are uh we
would like to uh
to study uh definitely we hypothesize
that the mothers are investing energy in
order to teach their
pups but i don't think that
vocalizations are involved by the way
there is the vocalization of other
popular organizations
something i think somebody mentioned
yesterday and
so when a mother is searching for its
pup and she left it on a tree and she's
coming back for example and she doesn't
find it
she will emit a very specific
vocalization that sounds like the
isolation chord you remember those
isolation chords that i played back
earlier i played back earlier
and so there are adult chords that sound
similar and the pop will start
responding
to these vocalizations whether it is
specific whether the pop recognizes his
mother and responds only to it i
i don't know but it's it's actually
heartbreaking to see a mother i've seen
it
searching for it's pop and shouting
these vocalizations but without any
response for sometimes
hopefully most of the time she does get
a response
um
yeah okay thanks joyce for the for the
comment uh
i think it's very interesting to compare
by the way although the bats are
probably
less uh working as a group than the
elephants
but in both cases it's a mammal with a
long-term memory
the fruit bats also memorize a an array
of different feeding sites so all of
this i think are commonalities that are
really interesting to
to compare um increasingly
yeah if you look at
[Music]
the adults so there is a study coming
from the hebrew university that came up
together i came out together with our
study recently like few weeks ago and we
looked at the pubs they looked at adults
and it seems as if the adults are more
stereotypical in their in their
movements
so i think that this exploration a lot
of exploration that we see decreases
over time
just like you you suggest uh
yes uh do you hear your footballizing
okay so except for this mother
vocalization that i've just mentioned
the answer is no and in general we
recorded the
multiple many species sorry you'll see
can you repeat the question not
everybody can see that question yeah
sorry the question was do you hear i
think i read it actually do you hear it
maybe very quickly
do you hear egyptian fruit bats
vocalizing when in flight so i said
except for um
for these mother cries that i mentioned
a few seconds ago
the answer is no and actually for
most bad species that we've observed uh
we don't see any social communication in
flight
which i find very interesting in the
case of the fish eating bats it seems
as if they are sometimes vocalizing but
mostly near the island
and not so much when they are out at sea
uh
the last question i'll read it and then
i'll shorten it only
yeah okay so the question this goes back
to the
to the second study i showed on vocal
intelligently where i showed you that
the um that if you remember the isolated
parts
they were much much less much more
dispersed in
in acoustic features space and much less
converged in comparison to the controls
and the question is whether we looked at
the trajectory so if you look i think
this this
question if you look over time uh how
does the movement look
towards the uh towards the area of the
adults
and the answer is we did it it's
fascinating with my student yourself pat
my former student and now with phd
created these beautiful movies where you
can see
uh and i can't say much about the
trajectories if you're interested in
exploring them we can find them i don't
think we even publish them
but it looks much more erratic so the
control group moves uh
directly steadily towards the uh towards
the adult
region while the isolated pups seem to
be moving all over the place
and at the end after a year we started
for a year
and they in many cases they don't reach
the adult zone
at all okay i say i have more questions
in the q a right
um i don't know do i have more time
um or maybe not
this is already answered right yeah i
think i answered this already
i think i answered everything correct
well do we have any other questions uh
yeah there is also there is also the the
discord channel
so you can also type questions uh
for all the speakers or general
discussions
so i guess we'll have a break now 15
minutes and then
we will return to the last session with
two talks about nlp
and early human learning